that are not CNF so constraint
programming answer set programming
operations research
and I will hand you over to John for the
first talk
good morning everyone
great to be here at UT Berkeley since
this is a workshop that deals with
satisfiability and logic and today we're
emphasizing optimization and constraint
programming I thought it might be fun to
have a an overview of the connections
between these fields because I believe
there are deep connections between the
three
that have led to a number of not only
practical algorithms but insights into
all three so I'll try to take you
through that
so connected to actually go back to this
guy George Google you've heard of him I
think
and I'm going to try to give you a
retrospective over the 170 years since
and perhaps into the future
because I think we see a trajectory here
of collaborative research and and
thought on the interface of these three
the Ulta has been very fruitful
so this is a spaghetti chart I'm going
to try to work you through so I'll I'll
guide you through this don't worry we
won't get lost but it shows that many
interconnections on the left you have
logic based ideas on the right
optimization based ideas and in red
constraint programming ideas which is
you see is intertwined uh among both of
the others
all right so our first trip through this
uh chart will be from Bool do constraint
programming how did that happen
okay well actually George we will
carried out a project that was begun by
lightness uh
many years earlier Google didn't know
about likeness until late in life but I
just believe that you could actually
construct a logical language in which
you could deduce all the derivatives in
science
and Bool began to implement that project
with his mathematical algebra of logic
of his work believe it or not was
actually forgotten for more than a
century
except for this guy Charles Sanders
purse philosopher
I have a background of philosophy so I
studied this guy in school well he was
interested in Bool
and
um he introduced multi-place predicates
the Boolean logic
and um are actually the quantifiers the
Google introduced the multi-place
predicates
and by the late 1890s we had a fully
formed first order logic banks that got
no Frey here
okay and then you know in that era
people like living Heinz Golem and
Deborah Bruce some theorems regarding
the semantics of Quantified logic
and of course airborne's compactness
theorem is studied in all logic courses
it turns out that there's a very close
connection between everyone's theorems
and integer programming
you know they may seem very distant
it would go something like this
everyone's theorem in logic you might
say is the fundamental theorem of first
order logic says that a formula first
order logic is unsatisfiable only if
some finite set of instantiations of
that formula ground level instantiations
where you have no quantifiers is
unsatisfiable okay well integer
programming we have a theorem
the infinite set of linear inequalities
is infeasible yes and only have some
finite subset of those inequalities is
infeasible okay not only look similar
but it's identical identical Theory and
the proof is the same we just change the
symbols change the language a bit you
have the same proof because absolute
oxymorphism between these two disparate
results just a taste of what's coming
now logic programming
eventually grew out of Boolean logic but
logic programming it was based on an
effort to combine procedural and
declarative modeling in the same model
so that you can receive you can read
every statement as stating a set of
constraints or propositions and is
giving instructions for how to deduce a
Solutions
well this became a fundamental idea of
constrained program in part to these two
people comorauer and Kowalski
how does it happen well if you know
first order logic a key step in
processing for store to formulas is
unification which is a process of making
two instantiations equal my proper
substitutions for the free variables
that's a little example here
well this was extended
the constraint logic programming by
observing that this unification problem
is really a constraint solving problem
you impose a constraint that teach these
two instantiations are going to be equal
that's a constraint and you solve that
constraint
well if you add dis equations unequal
you get prologue 2.
which is an extension of the original
prologue language
and you take that even further you get a
constraint logic programming where you
have not only these equations but
arithmetical constraints inequalities
and things of that kind
and this gave rise to cltr which is uh
constraint logic programming with real
value variables
and from there we go to the first real
constraint programming toolkit chip I
know some of the people who worked on
chip and originated this so Chip
introduced constraint propagation I
think we'll talk about shortly it
introduced finite domains Global
constraints all of these key Concepts in
constraint programming came out of Chip
which was so to speak a relaxation of
constraint logic programming dropped the
logical formalism and unification and
all of that but you keep the idea that
every constraint is both procedural and
declarative you process the constraints
in some order okay by reducing domains
and propagation filtration but you also
read the constraints as constraints as
stating the properties of the solution
you want
also we have a constraint that it's
faction leader reviewer which introduces
the idea of consistency which I'll also
talk about in a moment that's also an
area of amazing overlap between
optimization and constraint programming
and consistency determines how much
backtracking occurs if you try to solve
a problem by branching
okay
now how about satisfiability that began
with George pool as well okay so fool is
best known for his work in uh
propositional logic where you have no
quantifiers
uh and you see the path it goes down
from Google propositional logic to
satisfiability
it involves something called resolution
an inference method and something called
logic based vendors decomposition and
optimization so I'll try to uh expand on
this as we go along
now as I mentioned most of Google's
workers deals with propositional logic
so-called ground level propositions well
in 1950s this philosopher uh who was
another person I've read intentionally
when I was studying philosophy
Norman Klein
he proposed a method of deducing a
complete method of deduction for
propositional logic he called consensus
if you apply it to CNF rather than dnf
you get something called a resolution
and this is a resolution step here we
have two logical clauses
the X1 or X2 are X4 and so forth this is
the not that you probably know and from
those two you can deduce X1 or X2
you might see right away this is a
projection method you're projecting out
the proposition X4 these propositions
are true or false zero one variables
if you apply this over and over as is
well known you can deduce English
proposition you want
the Davis Putnam algorithm very famous
magistrative logic applied
uh resolution to the ground level
propositions that result from
instantiating first order formulas and
it was again a complete method of
inference
for first order of logic well resolution
of course is not only exponentially
complex in the worst case but in the
typical case it explodes
so a much more practical way to deal
with these propositions is by branching
on the values of the atomic propositions
and this is how we get dpll Davis Putnam
level and lotion method
I'll show you an example of that just a
moment
and of course this was the birthplace
for the very efficient satisfactility
the satisfability methods we have today
the key ideas one might argue and
cassette solvers are watched literals
really clever idea
and of course the big one is conflict
clauses conflict Clauses are going to be
Bender's Cuts in optimization
okay
here's a little example here we have a a
set of Clauses logical Clauses and we're
going to try to find a solution by
branching on the values of the atomic
proposition 0 and 1 are false and true
it turns out this formula is not
satisfiable so when we do a branch for
example we set X1 equal to false or zero
then we apply unit resolution as the
special case of that resolution
algorithm I mentioned from one of the
parents of the result that is a unit
Club it's one literal you know one
variable with a perhaps a knot in front
of it
okay and we keep doing like this until
finally begins a point where we obtain a
contradiction we deduce the empty Clause
using unit resolution so we have to
backtrack
we haven't found a solution by that task
well before we backtrack we're going to
do something called a conflict Clause
the conflict Clause explains why we have
a contradiction that explains why we can
prove unsatisfiability after we fix
those five variables to false
and this will allow us to avoid
the same mistake in the future if we
Branch over here now
we get another conflict Clause if you
put these two together we have to
backtrack all the way to here to avoid
violating these two Clauses and that
obviates having to search this entire
section of the of the tree okay it's not
back jumping an idea had been it at CMU
by the way
many years ago
get another conflict Clause here here
and this proves unsatisfiability so
obviously this consulate Clauses are
very useful they're still at the heart
of sat solvers okay
so I'm going to show you how we derive
this and publisher most of you know but
I'll show you the picture
where do we get it well we we either
picked the unit resolution proof
of contradiction using an implication
graph
where these are interpreted as
implications this is not x one or not x
five and plus not implies X6 for example
the implications are shown here by
arrows and we deduce the empty class
which proves contradiction
well what we do is extract something
called a conflict graph a sub graph that
proves a contradiction and with that
subgraph we partition it there are three
ways you can partition it there's one
way and the literals that are fixed in
the branching process on one side of
that partition
form the conflict clause
because we know that if you set those
two literals to true then you're going
to get a conflict you're going to get a
contradiction so they are responsible
for the infeasibility okay that's very
useful to know
as I mentioned we're going to show that
that is a vendor's cut later on exactly
the same thing
now so we've done set how do we get
there now we're going to do something a
little different decision diagrams
also came ultimately from George pool
here we go
decision diagrams came out of circuit
Theory through log Shannon
and decision diagrams are now used in
programming for filtering and constraint
propagation
I'll give you an example in a moment
so how did this work
I mentioned Charles Sanders purse the
guy who sort of only guy in the world
who was reading Google at the time
he realized you could apply Boolean
logic to switching circuits
this was in 1886.
so the birth of computing electronic
Computing actually occurred in 1886.
you should get credit for the computer
range in a way
of course
well in the 1930s there was this young
student University of Michigan named
Claude Shannon best known for
information Theory okay
well he was required to take a
philosophy course
now when I was a school I love
philosophy courses I expect he hated
them
but while he was taking the course
he was exposed to his book by purse
and anything in that book he saw this
idea of applying Boolean logic to
switching circuits so when he got to MIT
he wrote a master's thesis in which he
applied this idea to electronic
switching circuits
in his master's ageist is I think
undoubtedly the most famous Master's
thesis ever written
and it's often given credit for being
the birth of the computer age but
actually it occurred with Charles
Sanders purse in the 19th century
now meanwhile
Lee and Acres
develop diagrams
to show how to derive the output of a
logic circuit in a canonical way it
started with we who had you found your
decision programs and then Acres
replicated them with decision diagrams
Randy Bryant he's in the audience and
showed that for a fixed variable
ordering there's a unique reduced
decision diagram that represents a given
Boolean function of our given circuit
and from that point we have an explosion
of applications decision diagrams
in the design of logic circuits and
product configuration and so forth
so decision diagram basically says you
have a set of variables maybe X1 X2 X3
and the branches indicate whether you
set the variable to true or false and
you follow the corresponding path and if
you end up with a one you get a true for
the entire function the entire formula
in zero is false
now analysis applied to a constraint
program
well you know into free programming a
big idea is something called constraint
propagation
so we can trade programmers propagate
what they can conclude from one
constraint to the next constraint so
your recover straight programming
respecting the idea that you can process
the constraints one at a time it's
almost as though they were a computer
program
now in operations research we we don't
do that right we have a constraint set
that's a piece of whole cloth we
consider the constraints all
simultaneously we don't try to process
each constraint individually as though
they were statements in a computer
program
it's very programming you have a
processing element do I suppose we have
a little constraint set
with uh these two constraints
I mean the qualitative strength with
integer variables that can take the
value of one two three and in all
different constraint that says those
variables must take different values
you want the sagicide both of those
constraints how do you do that
but you'd like to put them together like
we do in operations research because
print programming can't do that so what
they do is they deduce something from
this constraint then they pass on that
information to the next constraint
constraint propagation
and what can you can deduce here is that
X3 can't have the value three it won't
work
because the others have to be one two or
three
that's called domain reduction or
filtering you filtered out the three
that's sort of the basic step
infrastrite programming solvers this
filtering idea okay very powerful idea
because it allows you to exploit the
structure of individual constraints but
then how do you make use of this
knowledge when you combine it with the
Dex constraint well you pass this
reduced domain down to the next
constraint and since you can reduce the
domains any further
so unfortunately in this case you can't
you have a look you think about it a
moment
if these variables can take any of these
values there's no way you can exclude
one of those values from a possible
solution of an all different
they're all possible
too bad so we didn't get very far
now suppose we add decision diagram for
this picture
rather than propagate the information
through the domains of variables we're
going to propagate the information
through a decision diagram
now what is this decision diagram
basically we have three variables we can
take these values
every path from top to bottom indicates
a possible set of variable values for
those three variables okay so example
that's right most path three one and two
for X1 X2 and X3
if every path is a possible solution
okay now uh in an exact decision diagram
you have precisely a representation of
all the feasible Solutions
of this inequality construct
I'm going to show you a relaxed decision
diagram that includes some additional
solutions that are not feasible why do I
do that because decision diagrams can
explode exponentially we don't want that
so we keep the decision diagrams small
by allowing ourselves to relax them to
introduce some spurious Solutions
so this is a relaxed decision diagram
which are easy to construct and there's
a whole literature on this now what do
we do
we want to incorporate somehow be all
different so we do a top-down
compilation which is every node of this
tree we take into account the fact that
the variables must have different values
this allows us to exclude some of these
arcs a very straightforward way it's
something like dynamic programming it's
very easy a linear time thing
and you get this
reduced decision diagram is still
relaxed but it's smaller and it's
tighter it excludes Solutions we had
before and in fact you see that possible
values of the variables are now
substantially reduced
the domains are reduced substantially
compared to what they were up here
just by using the relaxed decision
diagram as a medium of constraint
propagation rather than variable domains
so that's one way you can use decision
diagrams in constraint programs
in fact it turns out that if you want to
build an optimization solver then all of
the well-known functions of a solver can
be accomplished by
decision diagrams
uh modeling you can model any recursive
model as in dynamic programming in a
very natural way
you have a different type of search
which is more efficient it gets rid of
symmetry
you have Primal heuristics that is you
find feasible Solutions using heuristic
it works well you have a restricted
diagram for that
I mentioned constraint propagation and
post-op Melody analysis
okay
which is uh really just a perfect
application for decision diagrams
okay so that's the roles decision
diagrams in solving combinatorial
optimization problems that we see in
constraint program
now another
outgrowth
uh Boolean logic and optimization here
we go and that's probability Logics and
belief logics
so here's the path on top we're going to
start with Google again go to his
probability logic and then we'll find
ourselves ending up with linear
programming and integer program
okay
actually Bool thought that probability
logic was his most important
contribution you've probably never heard
of it
okay right in fact if you look at his
famous book
perhaps the most famous book ever
written in logic except for Aristotle
okay
the mathematical theories of logic and
probabilities
we always forget about that last word
you felt that was his main contribution
because he found a way of reasoning with
propositions that had only probabilities
and it's really very clever idea okay
the winner he was proud of it well again
that was forgotten for decades okay poor
guy okay uh it was rediscovered by this
by
sailburn a historian of logic Lehigh
University
he pointed out that Bulls probabilistic
logic is actually a linear programming
problem because you may know linear
programming is one of the the
foundations of optimization in fact the
most important problem in optimization
in a way the original problem in
optimization
through the birth of optimization
by the way the first linear programming
model saw by computer was solved in the
basement of the building where I work in
Pittsburgh and that was back in 1950
something okay anyway
and then Nielsen rediscovered the idea
for an AI application
well
apparently he had no idea it was Google
or haleburn Who had who were precursors
in this idea
how do you solve this like your
programming problem it turns out you can
use a method that's widely used called
column generation
okay uh
a generalization of something called
dancing wealthy composition in
operations research an optimization
method in fact if you flew to Berkeley
because I did
this the schedule of the flights and the
cruise was probably done by a column
generation method
baseball branch and prize
unfortunately Southwest doesn't seem to
use that method they had a meltdown
yesterday and I was afraid I wouldn't
get here at all all right but American
Airlines was the first to use uh problem
generation this was like 30 years ago
okay
so again a remarkable connection between
logic and optimization
I'll show you how it works
so suppose we have
these three formulas a a implies B and B
apply C I mean you have the
probabilities and we know the
probability with which we can infer C so
if they're all true we can use the first
C but they're only true with certain
probabilities so with what probability
can we in first see well what you do is
you write a linear programming problem
first you look at all the possible truth
values of a B and C are possible worlds
you might follow them
and you call the probability of each of
those outcomes
uh P zero zero zero and so forth we
don't know the value of these variables
yet but we'll just give them names
now we write constraints on the
variables okay for example statement a
is true in these four outcomes
see the one is in the first position in
those four
and they have to add up their
probabilities have to add up to 0.9
it's then relief for the others okay
they would want to minimize and maximize
the probability of C which is given by
this formula as you see the last element
is a one in each of these three because
that indicates we're talking about
probability that c is true
four cases then we normalize the sum
they're all non-negative listen when
your programming problem you know you
can solve this in an instrument
and this is the range of probabilities
you get for C you must have a
probability in that range
now I'm sure you may be thinking yeah
but the number of outcomes can be
exponential what do you do then you have
exponential number of variables no
problem
we solve the airline Staffing problem
right we use column generation and you
end up only generating a very small
fraction of the possible columns before
finding an optimal solution
so this is well-known technology in
operations research and it
it's probably I mean almost certainly
the first application
of this technology was to logic
okay now there's a number of other
non-standard Logics around the leaf
Logix temperature theory is very very
famous actually you can give density of
Schaefer Theory the very similar model I
just showed you only there we don't need
column generation we don't have an
exponential growth
uh non-monotonic logic
it turns out has a very nice integer
programming model this is logic in which
you can you can withdraw the conclusion
if you add an additional premise okay
it's not standard logic sometimes called
default logic
uh rule-based systems often have
confidence factors it gives you the
degree of evidence you have for the
propositions you can model the inference
of those confidence factors using mixed
integer linear programming energy
programming with perhaps some continuous
now
we're going to go to the other side of
the chart over here we're going to start
with Fourier
what does he do he had a theory of
really really quality this is where
we've got linear programming ultimately
and I'm going to show you some some of
the outcomes of that idea and in fact
we'll find out way down not only through
integer programming but into two key
elements of constraint programming I
mentioned filtering already The Edge
finding is a special case of that
so let's see how that goes
lamented Fourier uh developed the theory
of linear inequality many years ago and
a method for solving them that method is
actually almost the same as a resolution
that's that okay uh
moskin rediscovered it when we call it
Fourier moskin uh elimination yeah and
optimization with ritual
meanwhile
Santa
rosly the first to formulate an
optimization problem that with linear
constraints and objective function that
was done uh independently by George
stancik in the 1940s and dancing invaded
a solution method
where the linear linear optimization
problems
you can solve them using 38 muscular but
that's very slow
but dance solution method called the
Simplex method is actually so efficient
it's still the method of choice today
it's the only case I know of an
algorithm that has survived like 60 70
years with no basic improvements in it
wheels and whistles but basically the
same idea
it's incredibly fast well implemented
well these variables in the linear
programming optimization problem
can be restricted to integers there you
get integer programming which is now of
course a huge field with very good
solvers very high develop solvers
and we get the general field of
combinatorial optimization which
actually began with the traveling
salesman problem Dick Clark whose
picture is outside of course was a
Pioneer in studying the combinatorial
properties of travel and salesman
okay now this leads to two major success
stories in the cooperation between CP
and optimization one is Network flow
Theory which is a special case of linear
programming okay
that's applied to filtering methods I'll
show you an example in confront
programming
for a number of constraints
and if that turns out that Duality plays
a key role in that and something called
Edge funding which appeared in the
journal management science and or
Journal is now the Bedrock Foundation of
scheduling
Solutions in constraint programs
so here is a little example of network
flows here we have it all different
constraint I mentioned that before you
can model this constraint as a matching
problem you're going to match a value to
each of the variables here you have five
variables you're going to match one of
the values and the possible values are
given by the edges okay and if you can
find a perfect matching then you have a
solution of the all different
well how do we solve this what we really
want to do is not only solve it but see
if we can eliminate some of the values
from these domains
okay what do we do for that we we
reconce this as a flow problem having a
flow from a source to a sync and we
manipulate this in various ways then we
apply the Dual the linear programming
dual problem I'll talk about Duality
just in a moment and from this the Dual
solution we can obtain domain reduction
we can filter out most of these values
were the variables it makes the domain
smaller if we do have fewer values to
search as you solve the problem
okay that was the first application of
flows
to uh the constraints and there are many
others today
now in the area of edge finding Here We
Have a scheduling problem this is called
a grant chart so we have four jobs here
one two three and five and the time
Windows within which the jobs must be
processed or shown by these brackets and
the processing time that's shown by the
heavy line here okay so we're deducing
here that job 2 must precede jobs three
and five
job two must precede these two on the
bottom how do I know that well suppose
it didn't precedure suppose it weren't
first that means all three jobs would
have to take place between this earliest
time window here and this latest time
window here
well there's uh seven units of time
between those okay but the three jobs
together require eight units of time
they can't fit so the only alternative
is to schedule
job two first that's why it has to come
before the others
that means that you can reduce the range
of values where job two can be scheduled
and it turns out is reduced to the point
that you can't squeeze it in these two
right here so it overlaps and you have
empty ability
that's called Edge finding you can find
all the edge finding Solutions in
polynomial time if you're clever these
guys are very clever this was done back
around the year 2000 or so
and uh this has been generalized in many
ways in the constraint programming
literature particularly for so-called
cumulative scheduling where you schedule
many jobs simultaneously they can run in
parallel and so forth okay
so we have now a uh a huge literature
sorry at least a large literature based
on this Edge finding idea which came
from the optimization community and was
transformed into a constraint
programming research program
okay now we're going to start with
Fourier again and go down through this
optimization path
through linear programming
we're going to end up with something I
promised to show you namely that these
uh
these uh conflict Clauses are Bender's
cuts it's a bit of a long story but let
me show you how all this fits together
okay so I'm missing uh
38 already
well the next key ingredient with
something called Duality which I've also
mentioned where did that come from
this is one of the most remarkable
stories of coincidence that I know in
the field of mathematics and I I'm sure
it's true because dancing told me the
story himself and you're having dinner
once and he told me this story he was
involved so he happened to meet Jonathan
Neumann on the on the rail platform with
Princeton Junction New Jersey
one of them was visiting Princeton and
they got the talking and they realized
that phenomen was working on Game Theory
two-person non-cooperative zero some
games
Jesse was working on linear program
and then they came to the idea that if
you have a two-person game
of these conditions
one person's problem strategic problem
is a linear programming problem
the other person's
predicament is also a linear programming
problem and these two linear programming
problems are very closely related
they're Duels of each other
Duality okay so dancing took this ball
and ran with it in Duality now is not
only the most beautiful Concept in
optimization probably one of the most
useful as well it has you know it's just
sprouted uh implications far and wide
absolutely it's worth getting a PhD in
optimization to learn about duality it's
an amazing idea and it came from a
chance meeting on a rail platform would
it have happened otherwise
actually I don't think so
I don't think we would have a concept of
Duality you know LaGrange you know had
something like this multipliers or dual
multipliers in a way but it's really a
different approach uh I don't think we
would have the concept but for this
chance meeting
so here is uh a generalization of
Duality so we have a problem in which
we're trying to minimize the function
subject to constraints we're trying to
find the best feasible Solution by
searching over these values of some
Vector of variables the Dual problem is
to find the tightest possible bound on
the objective function if that you could
infer for the constraint set
your perspective it's the same problem
sort of think of Brockman and ottman and
Hindu from Hindu philosophy is sort of
like that is two different perspectives
on the same thing
uh but they're the same problem okay
and the linear programming Duality which
was discovered by dancing in phenomen is
a special case of this
foreign
Theory they're all special cases of this
inference Duality okay and the two
fundamental theorems
that relate to Duality to sarcoxual in
which everyone learns in authenization
101 and then your programming
the schwattal theorem which is the
fundamental theorem of integer
programming these two theorems show the
completeness of this duel is to say the
duel is exact the two have the same
value these two theorems are theorems of
completeness in logical deduction they
are logical theorems theorems of logic
showing that these two deductive systems
are complete okay so the two fundamental
theorems of linear integer programming
are theorems of logic
if you look at it from the perspective
of duality in this General sentence
now one one outgrowth of this Duality
concept was business decomposition one
of the most widely used optimization
methods and what it does is to note that
sometimes when you fix some of the
variables of the problem the problem
becomes much easier so what you can do
is try fixing these key variables to
various values and then for each set of
values you solve the problem that
remains which is called the sub problem
and that's much easier to solve it'll
often be couples into small problems
okay
now that problem where you you pick the
values of the main variable is called
the master problem
now when you solve the master problem
and get a value for some of the
variables then you solve the sub problem
you get the values for the other
variables you have to avoid trying that
solution in the future to do that you
write a constraint called a vendor's cut
in this business cut not only rules out
a set of values you just tried but a
number of other values that are bad for
the same reason it'll give you basically
the same result okay there's a lot of
cleverness in designing these vendors
cuts
the vendors cuts are the key to this
decomposition method that is now used in
a number of application errors I can't
even tell you on these thousands I'm
sure you use your phone right
uh the phone is based on the
Telecommunications Network they have to
allocate bandwidth
okay to the microwave to the towers okay
well that was done a few years ago when
the federal government the U.S had a
massive auction
to allocate bandwidth to the various
users of the electromagnetic spectrum
so this auction you know to tie the
winners pose an enormous combinatorial
optimization problem with tens of
thousands of constraints
that problem was solved
by failures decomposition or actually a
generalization of it because logically
expenditures decomposition so you can
use your phone thanks to him
okay now as I mentioned taking a logical
perspective it can allow us to
generalize fenders decomposition in a
way that you can solve that the Telecom
problem okay and it looks something like
this this is the classical vendors
method okay so you have this master
problem I mentioned over here you have
instead of trial values for some of the
variables then you solve the problem
that results it's called the subprovin
you send this Benders cut back the
English Cut looks like this for
classical interesting compositions where
the sub problem is a linear program
problem
now you get this vendors cut by Duality
okay but what we're going to do is to uh
extend this Duality to the inference
Duality I showed you a moment ago and
that means you can have any problem you
want as to so problems okay and you get
this generalization of vendors
okay so this is a case where a logical
perspective on the problem allows you to
generalize a classical method of
optimization of optimization to make it
much more General to a wider variety of
applications
okay
so this is what basically this says now
I claim that this conflict Clause isn't
set
are a special case of vendors Cuts why
is that true well look at this picture
again okay you Branch down to a certain
point in the Deep ell tree okay the
problem with that node is the sub
problem
the problem okay where do you get the
Clause the conflict Clause well you've
deduced increasability in this subproble
by using unit resolution and unit
resolution is is encoded in this
conflict graph
now
what is the Dual solution the Dual
solution is a proof of the infusibility
the solution of the inference tool is a
proof the proof of the infeasibility is
encoded in the way you derive this empty
cloth
now we're going to notice that the only
essential premises of this proof are
these two literals
okay so you look for the essential
premises of the proof and this is
exactly how you derive Bender's charts
by looking for the premises the variable
fixings that are essential to deriving
the result in the sub problem that gives
you the Defenders cut so this conflict
Clause is not only like a Bender's cut
it is a Bender's cut it is exactly the
same thing
so the heart at the heart of the set
methods we have this idea
of duality
from optimization
I think that's nice
okay now cutting planes
we're going to wrap this thing up with
cutting points
so cutting planes as you may know are
the Workhorse of integer program okay
they look something like this at the end
of the programming we have a constraints
have this linear inequalities but we're
trying to find an integer solution one
of these red dots but the inequalities
are like the blue lines they don't uh
really exactly describe the feasible set
we'd like to have the convex follow the
feasible set which is this then we could
just take a we can just maximize the
function subject to this this set of
inequalities that describes the convex
Hub the titanium compact cell is very
difficult so we try to approximate the
convex I'll let these cutting planes
like this so as to reduce the size of
the relaxed problem we get from Simply
relaxing the integer constraint on the
variables
so deriving these cutting planes is a
key idea in making integer programming
problems tractable the idea is basically
came from Roscommon brilliant guy
well
I mentioned resolution
remember this this is a little
resolution step it's actually a
projection method
I also mentioned that you can solve in
your programming problems in a way
that's similar using Fourier masking
elimination so this is Fourier must
illumination you just take a linear
combination
and you get this result
okay and if you do this over and over
you can actually solve it in your
programming problem now I'm going to
round up the right hand side
if I round up the right hand side I get
a 1 here
that's the resultant
do you take Fourier mosque elimination
round up the right hand side and you've
got the resolution method of Willard Ben
Ormond flour
the foundation doesn't they just cutting
them out of it
and so Davis Putnam is cutting plane
Theory defended your program
not only that
there's more
there's a theorem the fundamental
theorem of cutting plane Theory
obtained by chateau
that's why we call the SWAT algomery
cuts the funimal theorem says you could
if you repeat this step over and over
taking uh this uh
this rounding step do this linear
combination over and over in various
ways you could generate all the possible
cutting planes
a remarkable theorem it's that simple
step replied repeatedly will generate
all the possible cutting Flames just by
applying resolution over and over will
generate all the possible implications
of a cloud set
okay
well how do you prove this theorem of
schwatal
very few of my students actually look at
the proof but if you look at his proof
that's at the core of the proof
there's no resolution method
somehow learned about resolution I don't
know how
and he put this idea to work to prove
the fundamental theorem of energy
approach
so a fundamental fundamental logic based
method of inference why is it the heart
of integer program
and vice versa
okay now I also mentioned briefly
consistency another very important idea
at new Strength program management is
basically you know I'm I'm simplifying
what I do here a great deal but a
consistent constraint set is one such
that if you take a partial assignment to
the variables that cannot be completed
to satisfy all the constraints that
partial assignment violates some
individual constraint
so the exclusion of infeasible partial
assignments it's explicit because it's
done by individual constraints you can
easily check whether a partial
assignment is feasible now why is this
important because when you do branching
right you're branching down through this
tree at any given node you have a
partial assignment to the variables and
you want to know whether you should
continue if there's no feasible
extension of that partial assignment you
want to backtrack you don't want to
continue so it's very useful to be able
to recognize infeasible partial
assignments you can always recognize
them just by checking each individual
constraint you've got consistency now of
course in CP we use various weaker forms
of consistency called domain consistency
and so forth our consistency
all right so in CP we look for partial
types of consistency but nonetheless
this is a Workhorse in constraint
programming solvers
yeah what about cutting points as I
mentioned before cutting planes are
generally viewed as cutting off part of
the relaxed constraints that you don't
want the fractional solutions that you
get before you restrict the variables to
integers you want to cut those off so
This Is How We Do cutting claims they
cut off fractional Solutions and that
gives you a tighter bound on the optimal
value when you're doing your branching
it's called branch and valve okay so
this isn't the way we view cutting
planks for about 60 years
since they were invented but cutting
claims also achieve consistency and one
reason that cutting planes work is that
they are increasing the degree of
consistency of the constraint set you
can forget all about fractional
Solutions and all of that stuff in
Balance they're just increasing the
degree of consistency which allows you
to recognize
when you have an infeasible partial
assignment in half the backtrack
so as far as I know this has never been
recognized in the 60 years of integer
programming literature even though it's
a totally basic uh property of cutting
point but if you take this logical
perspective from constraint programming
you see what's going on here and you can
actually apply this okay this is you
know very new stuff here's a little
example uh here we have a constraints
that is not consistent because setting
X1
the one does not violate any of the
constraints but it's not a feasible
solution they'll teach these are the two
integer solutions that are feasible
that means you just keep branching
rather than knowing that you can't go
any further after you said X1 equal one
if you had a cutting plane that looks
like something like this
then this cuts off
the solution X1 equals one and you
backtrack without wasting any time
all right
yeah
the form of consistency that works
particularly well for integer
programming is something we might call
LP consistency linear programming
consistency
and it basically it says that if you
have a partial assignment that cannot be
extended then this partial assignment is
infeasible in the linear programming
relaxation of the problem where you drop
the integer constraints on the variables
okay so I'm going rather fast here but I
just want to show you the basic idea so
here we have again this uh this problem
that's not LP consistent because there
are solutions that satisfy
uh the lp relaxation where X1 equals to
one X1 can be equal to one in the lp
relaxation which is this area
inside the red lines okay but if we had
a covering plane like this
and we cut off this part and we now find
that setting x one equal one violates
the linear programming relaxation of the
problem and we backtrack without wasting
time okay
now this is not just any cutting plane
remember I mentioned the fundamental
theorem of integer programming you can
apply this algomery cut this is how to
rank one shot Algoma cut if you apply
these cuts it generate them over and
over you have a complete method for
generating cutting planes that's what
I'm doing here
you only have to use these rank one cuts
to achieve this type of consistency in
fact there's a theorem that is even
stronger you only have to achieve rank
one schwato algomery cuts it derive all
the logical clauses
from the constraint set
so you can achieve consistency for
integer programming
by applying this theorem from Theory
which is itself
an insight into the application of
resolution to integer program the
logic-based method
okay and in fact if you do this you
actually get a more reduction of the
search treated you get with conventional
separating cutting planes that people
have been using for 16 years
okay
uh that's my show so what I've done here
is try to try to list briefly some of
the research areas that lie on this
interface of CP logic I had constraint
programming you see there are quite a
few the first few are very important you
know they're the basis of whole fields
okay the others are more sort of more
more specialized
so maybe this can continue I mean it's
been going on for 170 years
maybe it's uh you know conducive for us
to think about ways to apply the
insights of these disparate fields
when we approach a problem
right so thanks for your attention
[Applause]
thanks for a wonderful presentation so
uh the future you know what what this
covers are awaiting us where where do
you think we should go next yeah in the
past I have tried to project the course
of research and have always been totally
wrong so I really think you can't
say I mean I can't say where this is
going to go and this of course is what
makes research exciting right you never
know what you're going to discover so I
really I'm sorry I just don't know how
to answer that but I think perhaps this
is a direction that released based on
the trajectory you followed so far
something along these lines may continue
uh hi uh very nice presentation thank
you uh
you had one line about satisfiability
modular Theory I would be curious too
yeah yeah so it's that modulo theory
absolutely
I brought that up so what happens is
that modulo theory so most is I
understand I'm not an expert in this
area but most of the solvers basically
are based on either dpll or a set
algorithm okay to do the process The
Logical constraints and the problem and
then the the other constraint like the
arithmetic constraints the theory is
passed off to a subsolver okay and you
solve that part of the problem given the
current mode of the of the search okay
and then you pass back a conflict clause
or something of that kind to direct the
rest of the logical search so what's
going on there it's exactly what you're
but you do with conflict Clauses so here
the sub problem is the theory in the
satmodulo theory okay that's the sub
problem of the benders
so that's the vendor cell problem and
the conflict Clauses you pass back are
the Bender studies there's not only like
business decomposition it is vendors
decomposition it is
that's a remarkable thing and something
like you know hitting sets it's a
special case of that
thanks so so yes yesterday I was told
that this
that there's a bandwidth allocation
problem
resolved by a sad solver but now you
said it would result by cutting plane
methods so I like to sort of find out
what what the truth Is Here Yeah so
basically uh everything with the kitchen
sink was used to solve this problem so
you know sat uh cutting planes and IP
for all ingredients okay but in the end
it had to be decomposed so the the sub
problem turned out to be the
interference constraints right when you
have uh antennas using the same
frequency you want to make sure they're
not too close to each other so you have
no interference you have tens of
thousands of those as I understand it
that's the part that went into the sub
problem
of the Menders okay so the sort of the
the overall architecture was a vendor's
decomposition
my second question is can you go back to
this uh uh relaxed
decision diagram slide uh
yeah okay
go too far
I I don't want to take too much time to
walk me through this again
okay so what it means is first we're
looking we're enumerating some possible
values for the three variables yeah in
each path from top to bottom
uh indicates a set of values for those
three variables
okay so most of the paths that we follow
here uh
satisfy the inequality from strength not
all of them because it's a relaxed side
so this is basically uh uh nodes Branch
points okay so here you Branch the first
variable could be one two or three you
branch on those and you Branch them
x two equal two and x two equal three
leaves at the same point at the
yes yeah so this looks a little bit odd
right setting X2 to 2 R3 to lead you to
the same node here
okay well that often happens in decision
diagrams I understand that but what is
the node mean yeah so what the node
means is that the branching
opportunities after you set x two to two
or three are the same oh okay it doesn't
matter yeah
actually they're it's combined here
because of the relaxation mechanism
I was going to ask you a different
question since we're on the slide um I
was wondering if you could articulate
the principle by which the decision
diagram is relaxed or accepting some
spurious assignments is it easy to say
which ones yeah so there are two main
ways that they're relaxed one is that
you start with a single path and between
every adjacent node you have all the
possible values or the variables and
then you split some of those nodes to
rule out some of the uh the bad
Solutions so you have a splitting
mechanism okay you use a heuristic to
find the best split the other approach
is emerging you start out and start
creating compiling an exact diagram you
have to get too wide then you merge some
of the nodes okay and you merge the
states that go along with them so
actually what we're doing here is a is a
state transition graph for a dynamic
programming model you can interpret it
that way so when you emerge nodes are
emerging the states and if you use the
right merger rule which can be which can
be stated in theorems use the right
merger Google that will give you a
relaxed valid relaxed diagram so there's
two main those two main mechanisms so I
always use the the merger I like that
better but people have had a lot of
success with the splitting as well for
example traveling salesman in the time
Windows you know very vulnerable problem
you can just knock the top out of that
problem by using decision diagrams with
splitting
so then the the bigger question
um this is a really nice talk and make a
compelling case for how completeness
theorems from one area apply very
naturally to other areas I'm one thing
that I've observed is that solvers in
these different areas are heuristically
good at to what uh at least in my eyes
seem like very different kinds of
problems
um I you know I can take uh my SAT
instance and I can encode it as an ILP
and the ILP solver will be terrible on
it empirically but of course the reverse
is also true and so I'm curious just
what you think of the apparent
Divergence in terms of heuristic
performance in these areas is that
something is that an opportunity to try
to sort of reach some kind of parity or
is that very natural
yeah so I guess if I knew that I'd win
the Nobel Prize I mean I uh that's the
big question right I mean how do you
discern the best approach so I I like
the no free Lux theorem right which
basically says that it doesn't matter
how you solve a problem unless you
exploit that problem's special structure
you know all general purpose algorithms
are basically the same you know until
you start looking at the special
structure of the problem so once you
understand the structure uh then you can
perhaps have some insight into which
method can exploit that structure
yeah that's the way I look at it yeah
I really can't get to the general I mean
that's that's what I get paid to do you
know Case by case right it's also called
you know the the what is it the job
security theorem or something like that
so to just back to decision diagrams
again I think it might be the next slide
just here where you said
um
your decision diagrams can perform all
functions of an optimization solver yeah
so how does how is branch and bound
replaced
by decision diagrams okay so in
conventional branch and bound you simply
branch on the variables and you
construct a tree okay so now what we're
going to do is Branch within a relaxed
decision diagram
so one possible way of doing this is
that you start constructing the decision
diagram okay and at some point it gets
too wide and you start relaxing it you
start merging nodes but the last level
where you have an exact diagram you say
okay I'm going to branch on those nodes
and each of those nodes you're going to
construct a new relaxed tree when you
relax a diagram I mean okay and that
relaxed diagram will give you a bound
which is much like solving the linear
programming relaxation at a branch and
bound method to get a bound from that so
rather than to solve the lp relaxation
you're solving a relaxed decision
diagram at your branching nodes now why
do you want to do this because this
relaxed decision diagram within which
your branching contains a lot of
information about the problem you've
already discovered by constructing a
product decision diagram so you're
exploiting all this information
uh before you start branching okay so
you don't sort of have to play around
and find a good branching order
also you get rid of multiple symmetry
the same way so which is a big problem
in branching
question
thank you very much for the interesting
talk I have a million questions but I'll
ask one about
the mdds in practice every time I use
the mpts I observed the order of
variables matters greatly do you have
any insight about how to choose that
yeah so so Randy Bryant did you hear
somewhere can probably tell you a lot
about that uh so what I do you know my
approach to this is that uh I would use
mdds usually when the problem already
has a recursive model because they're
most uh applicable to that type of model
and the recursion itself gives you the
variable order so that's the most
natural way to me it's like you know you
know actually you know recursive models
are a real problem for optimizers we
have to use dynamic programming or
approximate stochastic chroming and all
this stuff this stuff is you know it's
hard to use it's have to be you know
really tailored to the problem it
explodes it's a new way of approaching
these uh recursive models that makes it
analogous to a branch imbalance
thank you very much
[Applause]
we now have a break for coffee
foreign